[Music]
hello everyone oh the mics are working
magical
my name's isabel mcneal and i'm a fellow
at trinity hall at the university of
cambridge my research area is french and
film hello everyone i'm michael robiniak
i'm a lecturer in english modelling
college cambridge and
i specialize in visual culture and
interdisciplinarity we're going to start
by talking a little bit about tactics uh
because
i
came into the job that i do directly out
of my phd i just finished my phd i was
very fortunate and i got a job in a
cambridge college so you know
i was excited i was feeling good about
myself
and
as the years went by then i had children
and i you know i
started feeling the the strains and the
pressures of the job increasingly
and after a while i noticed that
um you know people were
overtaking me in the in the sort of
career ladder and um
then then my mum died and i was just
devastated we were really really close
we were best friends really
and so all of these things kind of came
together
and
i realized that there was something
profoundly missing something profoundly
wrong with the experience of this job
that i loved
why did i want to do it i wanted to do
it because i was curious intellectually
curious because i loved film i was a
massive cinephile
because i wanted to write and i wanted
to talk with students about how to write
about film and how to
discover french culture through film
um
and suddenly it just all felt like there
was something massively missing in all
of this and one of the main things that
was missing was a sense of creativity
when i had my kids i started
sewing and it became like a guilty
secret that i couldn't tell any of my
colleagues because it would seem too i
don't know too homely and too domestic
and then i started talking with people
and i discovered that actually some of
my colleagues who i knew very well also
had these creative hobbies on the side
and i thought there's something wrong
that that has to be secret you know why
couldn't that nurture our intellectual
endeavors why couldn't that be a part of
what we talk about with students
and at this time i happen to be reading
the practice of everyday life by the
french philosopher michelle decerto
and i came across this brilliant idea
that that he has
called the peru the peru it just
literally means wig in french
but what what it means it's when um
it's when the workers basically use the
resources of their employers for their
own purposes so they're not stealing
they're not directly taking things from
their employers but they are
perhaps taking a bit of time carving out
a bit of time to do something that maybe
that is not directly part of their paid
employment
and they're doing this in solidarity
with the other workers so together they
are kind of uniting in this tactical way
and i thought yeah we could do something
like this in cambridge cambridge needs
us to do something like this we need to
do something like this to sustain our
our sense of aliveness in academia
and so colleagues and i started
collaboratively and that was obviously
given what i've just said hugely
important aspect of it we started this
group called tactics and praxis praxis
being the idea of making being that idea
of doing something practical which in
cambridge seemed to be rather frowned
upon
and
bringing that together with um this
tactical approach where we were going to
use the resources of the institution
itself
um to work against it and we were
thinking you know here we weren't just
thinking about our own kind of feelings
of
of lack really but we were thinking
about all of our students we were
thinking about the mental health crisis
amongst students we were thinking of
the institutionalized racism we were
thinking of the institutionalized sexism
and we were thinking about ways to
resist all of this by coming together in
creative ways
so we started doing some seminars
and in the very first one we booked a
room so that was part of it we got some
funding from the institution we got
rooms from our institution
so we were using their resources and
using our time
and we walked into the room and we just
thought
this is an institutional space we've got
to do something about it so
it became very much part of our of our
way of doing things that we would always
have we would always dress the room so
we would always bring
things to
humanized to soften this institutional
space so today even today because i
thought today here in the hat tent you
know we wouldn't really need it but
somehow even today it's it's a way of
kind of changing that atmosphere even
for us as speakers it makes us feel
like our creativity can flourish in this
space
and this is my tea for tactics
and cushion that i made full of all
kinds of donated fabrics and gifts um
we're very much interested in
in gifts um and sharing and exchange in
our in our group
um and one of the first um
people to come to these tactics and
practice seminars that became a whole
movement really um was michael
and so michael has been part of part of
it from the beginning really because he
was always there
um so i think that's where i'm going to
hand over to michael now who's going to
to say a few words in sort of in
response and in dialogue with tactics
and praxis yeah i'm i'm going to talk
about um a new experimental university
that isabel is is very much part of and
really which grows out of tactics and
practice and takes on board all that
isabella's just been saying about need
to bring in that stuff that is
marginalized that is cast asunder by the
notion of professionalism
to bring in ideas of creativity the body
the hand crafts personship
and so the new school of the
anthropocene um is something that i've
been pulling together for the last two
or three years
it's it's a collaboration with the
october gallery in in bloomsbury and
i guess what we're trying to do here is
to bring this um the the
the ideas that isabelle has just shared
into a more institutional milieu and
work out how we can change
the institution of the of the university
itself because we've got a very
significant framework here of
bio-political emergency you know an
immediate future that was prophesied in
last month's ipcc report of unimaginable
climate catastrophe species extinction
desertification sea level rises i'm sure
you're all familiar with this and of
course
this is taking place
alongside a rise in authoritarian
regimes
that undermine the very reciprocal basis
of civic society across the world
so the question we're asking with this
new universities is how do we
how can we
reshape the institution
to address this in the context of the
university's own crisis
of marketization instrumentalism
paralyzing levels of graduate debt
and also crucially the the denigration
of the arts and the humanities
which has been accelerated even further
by the government's recent announcement
of a 50
cut
in funding to courses from this year
so the question we want to ask is how do
we best equip students to deal
with these problems give them the
necessary critical and creative
confidence to make interventions
um to ensure the perpetuation of life
on earth
and so the new the new school is rooted
in an understanding that the current
models of higher education are
increasingly unserviceable they're
steeped in what we can think of as
managerial realism a way of running an
organization that cannot think outside
of
bureaucracy tears compliance
an erosion of trust and need to define
every relationship and practice
how do we
move away from an institution that now
openly simulates the practices and the
inequalities of corporate business and
this of course includes the scandalous
pay levels of vice chancellors which are
now edging towards 400 000 pounds a year
while the majority of undergraduate
teaching is
undertaken
by casual casualized staff
so this is a sector that's marked by
overworked demoralized
over-managed lecturers
um and students who are struggling with
very significant mental health anxieties
anyone who's been involved in higher
education over the last 10 years i'm
sure can testify to this extraordinary
acceleration in this ease amongst the
students and i think this probably
hit a new low last year with the um the
gamble with student lives that was
undertaken by universities instructing
students to return into residence in the
full knowledge
the most teaching will be conducted
online
the reason for this of course to collect
the student rents and we had that
ghastly spectacle of security fences
erected in manchester to incarcerate
students
this is a very much a consequence of the
2012
government funding settlement which
transformed students into financialized
units
and plunged many higher educational
institutions into crippling levels of
debt
so to our mind this is an extraordinary
way to run a public service
so we're exploring what the viable
postcovid university might look like
and in so doing we find that engaging
with a mainstream is increasingly
difficult
hence the need to consider parallel
shifts alternative forms
of organization where whereby agency
might be recovered by the individual and
the collective alike and crucially that
principle of conviviality
might be restored
so the new school is one such response
it's a self-organizing cooperatively
founded it's it's run by academics who
come from cambridge and across the
university world in collaboration with
artists and practitioners
the aim of the new school is to run this
as cheaply as possible as
non-bureaucratically as possible with
minimal tuition fees as a means of
releasing students from the tyranny of
debt
there are no governors boards of
trustees managerial tears everyone is
paid the same we we hope to take our
first cohort of 15 students
next september
at the moment we think the fee will be 1
900 a year we're hoping to attract
bursaries
there will be no degree awarded
the idea being that
recognition is not necessarily the same
as accreditation
um
and the key question is how do we design
a curriculum that reflects educational
value
beyond the enhancement of personal
market worth so at the new school that
the students will co-design their
learning uh they'll be regarded as
researchers in the very beginning
um and they and with the recognition all
of us
are creatively generative intellectually
curious
and will be assigning equal stress to
the critical and creative act to
individual development and collaborative
action
and to the hand and the body as well as
the mind
so this implies that there will be more
traditional higher educational
activities such as philosophy literary
criticism visual culture film editing we
have anthony wall from bbc arena and
chris pettit the independent filmmaker
who'll be running editing courses but
there will also be courses in
permaculture soil stewardship
at the sitopia city farm down in
greenwich
dance printmaking creative writing and
even wild swimming as overseen by isabel
so it's a kind of black mountain college
this great experimental institution in
north carolina that ran in mid-century
um
a black mountain college for the digital
era is the way we like to conceptualize
it
the point of departure is felix
guattari's 1989 book the three ecologies
which is about the intersecting and
interdependent
spheres of the mind society and the
environment with meaning being made both
within and between
those spheres
and the major impulse here is that sense
that we we can do better for our young
people and for returning adult learners
which at the moment means these people
need to acquire a sixty thousand pound
debt
as a threshold to adulthood
to ensure some kind of form of social
participation it's a debt that's called
service par currently
at six percent interest a year
now this just give a bit of further
context before we open this up uh this
this week there was a survey for the
lancet
uh that was pre-published called young
people's voices on climate anxiety
government betrayal a moral injury a
global phenomenon that interviewed 10
000 young people under the age of 25
from 10 countries and it revealed that
three quarters
agreed with the statement that quote the
future is frightening
50 percent reported feeling distressed
and anxious
with regard to climate breakdown and its
effects on their daily functioning
so in such a context the new school will
seek to explore how a higher education
might prepare students to forge new and
viable futures to be passed on to the
generations to come how the university
might shift away from this relentless
focus
on survival in the present
preparing students to compete for a job
reproducing the destructive practices of
the present
and that includes what the late david
graber termed [ __ ] jobs
last week the vice chancellor of the
highlands and islands announced his
intention to cull and i quote vanity
courses
in the service of workforce alignment
and supply and in so doing he exposes a
dualism between that higher
the traditional higher educational
function which is the exploration of
knowledge
of how meaning is actively made
and that new preoccupation with training
and skills
we're preparing students to operate
administrative procedures
rendering them quote office ready
so the public university is here quite
damagingly being reinvented as a trade
school
so in such a context we want to ask how
edu how higher education can recover
those more expansive horizons
by serving the imagination and in so
doing address ecological collapse and
restore confidence in a participatory
democracy
so this is not a sentimental bid to
reinstate a pre-1990s version of the
university we've had screeds of
brilliant analysis on the effects of the
2012 marketization in the lrb in the
guardian over many years but it's a bid
to create a more agile institutional
model less constrained by business
practices and open to collaboration with
other arts and educational organizations
and one that could ideally be kept small
and replicated and rolled out regionally
so the new school is is really a
supplement
not a replacement of the he mainstream
one that insists that the function of a
college is to teach students
rather than provide them with the uni
package
it's an ethos that of course is not for
everyone but it is for anyone
and to sum up i just want to call up two
recent articles one came out this week
in the irish times with a very fine
journalist finland o'toole
who identified a broader international
effort and i'm quoting him here to make
education more and more managerial to
insist on a rational relationship
between inputs and outcomes
to reproduce only those forms of
knowledge that we already have it is now
anathema to tolerate a system that
allows people to do things we haven't
planned and cannot measure
and the second piece is from the sunday
times from the 8th of august
that expose the proposals of the
university
to continue online teaching in the new
academic year in response to pandemic
demands
and this piece
framed
binary relations between producer
interests by which it meant university
teachers and administrative
administrators and what it called
consumer interests the the the students
themselves
and it railed against the the control
that it was imposed upon the later group
who'd made a personal investment in
their education and the the piece
frame this in terms of an infringement
of consumer rights
i'm interested in how we got to this
awful place this false
and destructive set of assumptions
that final internalization
of marketization in this wonderful
environment of the university so coming
from completely different positions both
pieces i think view higher education
currently
as a set of wheeled premises to be
fulfilled an administrative spoon
feeding of a finished product rather
than a shared investigation and a
negotiation of meaning between teacher
and student
so in the face of this rather
mechanistic customer notion of education
we're looking to explore how we might
restore the adventurous life of the mind
as a legitimate value in and of itself
how we might reconcile
those producer and consumer interests
and as we face the very real prospect of
the end of life on earth
how do we reinstate that principle of
wonder
before the world
so neither of us in our respective
actions have definitive answers but
we're keenly aware of the questions i
think
okay thank you
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv
you